if there is
anything that needs to be uh satirized
and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way
extra points if you can sample trump
saying massive dumps and me talking
about it in a song
big massive dumps
that it was massive dumps that led
as opposed
what is going on here what is going what
is going on here
it's just beyond parody a massive dumps
cost of the election
what is going on here what is going what
is going on here it's just beyond parody
massive dumps cost the election
what is going on here what is going on
dumps
all right welcome everybody we have uh a
big announcement on the coronavirus and
fighting
for vaccination we have to fight people
so that they will get vaccinated it's
crazy but we're going to hear from
president joe biden momentarily my
prediction
is that joe biden just bans the virus
today
just make it illegal and and let's move
on you know why even toy around with it
declare it a felony and let's just be
done with
it you know i mean it's like this has
been going on long enough so that's my
expectation we're going to
be hearing from joe biden um in about 15
minutes and we have a few
different things to talk about i will be
looking at super chats i will be playing
some voicemails i have an unban request
to adjudicate
i have a couple of videos new york city
is going to
enact a vaccine requirement if you want
to go to restaurants
you want to go to a restaurant you're
going to have to show proof of
vaccination and yes
people are going to fake their
vaccination cards of course it's going
to happen of course it's going
it's already happening in fact and
and and i have something very special
today i recorded an interview
with mike pillow this was my face at the
start of the interview
this is for a future episode of the show
i will pre-release a minute
of the mic pillow interview i'll just
even just for proof let me show you
okay just for proof and he would not
stay in the middle of the frame he kept
going off to the side
i will preview one minute of this
interview
for every 10 website members and twitch
subs
if we get to 100 i'll give you the whole
interview okay this is for a future
show but i will preview this it is
heretofore
unseen my friends um this is the
beginning
okay so that is that it is absolutely
real let's see where we are right now
cryptic just subscribed ollie the savage
subscribed
dra noah gifted five
christina subscribed
catastrophic failure subscribed
and gazian subscribed as well as
aunt fufu putting us at 11. so we've
earned a minute
okay we're already a minute we we have
earned a minute of
pillow so let's listen to the first
minute
here we go uh mike i really appreciate
the uh now by the way
see how he was signaling he was yelling
at people the entire interview there
were moments where i was the only one on
screen
he was he was furious the entire
interview with his staff okay so it's
already crazy opportunity to chat with
you today
thanks for having me on of course so
listen
you first came to my attention i first
became aware of you
at the start of the pandemic donald
trump held this event at the white house
and announced
here are some business people that are
going to be doing things to help us
you were going to be if i recall
correctly making masks and maybe even
some other things how did you first come
to to meet donald trump and that
relationship start
well it was the summer of 2016
uh he invited me to trump tower i was
august 15 2016. it was a private meeting
i went in there it was about 35 minutes
just him and i
and i walked out of there and i didn't
you know i didn't i come from a past of
it
all right that's that's one minute i
promised one minute and i would do a
minute for every 10
subs okay so that's what we've got so
far
inconsolable jay tandaway just gifted
five each
elliot sloan thinka 12
kind to guppy gets us up to 17.
oh boy so now that puts us at 28 that's
another minute
okay oh hold on a second and also
william brown just signed up on my
website with the coupon code myhipaa29
all right so we've got another minute of
pillow okay let's continue
addiction and stuff i didn't think
politics affected anything but i did
walk out of his office said
he's going to be the greatest president
ever if he's if he's
with all the things we talked about we
talked about you know
my pillow being made in the usa we
talked about i said i was going to have
a
a platform which i do the lindell
recoverynetwork.org which helps addicts
and he said i'm going to stop the drugs
pouring in
and we we just had this back and forth
and i went to my
uh went to his employees afterwards and
i i asked them i kind of did my due
diligence i'm going
is this real i mean the only agenda he
had was to help our country
and to help people and that's what i and
they all said yes this is one of the
most insane interviews i've ever done by
the way
amazing boss amazing man and they all
had a personal story about him
and then boy i got back to minnesota and
i did a press release and
you didn't think i shot someone they
attacked me and called me a racist
and called me everything and all i did
was say i had a meeting with uh
with donald trump yeah it was running
for president
you uh all right that is the second
minute okay
we're doing we're doing a minute of this
for each 10 subs
um i do want to say thank you to william
brown who just signed up on my website
with the coupon code my hipaa getting us
another minute
also ali the savage has gifted five nick
lovin is six squeegees is seven
droops is eight mad satchel is nine
balcon gorm is ten
uh putting us at forty alright so that's
two more minutes of pillow
this is crazy at that event at the white
house that i mentioned at the start of
the pandemic
you you said that donald trump was quote
chosen by god
how how did god reveal to you that that
he had chosen trump
that's a good question right it was a
bunch of divine appointments for me i
had a dream in the spring of 2015 that
i'd be meeting donald trump and i'm
going why would i want to meet donald
trump and all of a sudden
he's okay by the people joining this has
not been released yet okay we're
previewing this
on the escalator running for president
then i had if you
in my book i i explain all this i i
actually
to the national prayer breakfast in
early 2016 and when ben carson was still
running for office
and i was picked out of 12 people out of
the whole prayer breakfast with
thousands there
to pray out of to with uh ben carson in
a room
and um just these things kept happening
to me
and it was like building up and i'm
going this all has to mean something and
uh it wouldn't mean that i just end up
going golfing with donald trump or
something
and and uh like there was so many divine
appointments that led up to that
and then uh i just uh it was something
different something that you know
because
i met him i just know this had all these
things that happened i look at the to
know that god exists
i use mathematics and say if you have a
one in a million happen or a one in a
billion
or this thing or this thing happens that
could never happen
when do you add them together and
consider a miracle and that's what kept
happening to me and i'm going
i go this he's been picked he's been
chosen for such a time as this wow so if
i hear you correctly you're saying
what others might see as odds and
probability
you see as divine appointment absolutely
it wow
especially when there's more than one
and then there's confirmations of that
wow you know here's a guy for me being
just an ex-addict from minnesota
a guy very functioning attic you know
growing up
and uh and here i end up in the i end up
in the white house i'll tell you an
example
so i end up all right so we are that's
the four minutes that we've
we've gotten so far we're doing a minute
for every 10 subscriptions
oh man there may even be more hold on a
second justin volts just signed up on my
website with the code myhipa
and jacob steinle just signed up with
the code better21 that puts
us at 42. also via twitch clint eastwood
kind af mr bonales lucky auntie mame
um have signed up that's four putting us
at 46. okay so we're not yet at another
minute of it
but we're doing one minute of pillow
interview
uh for every every 10 website and twitch
subs
let me look at some super chats brett
says congratulations sir
yes exactly congratulations sir you just
won the election
pair says damn i'm already a member
natural born
keeler says hey david keep up the good
work greed greetings from kier
keel north germany
pim tool says generally agree but it's
too nuanced and reductive
christopher eggett says i love eating
cornbread good for you
chakuseki says david make this a regular
segment called pillow talk with pacman
um
david huge fan do you believe
republicans care about the fact that the
vaccine is not approved by the cdc
the cdc doesn't approve medication so i
don't know why i mean it's just
i have no idea pim tool says we know you
will soon release the entire video it
will get many views why play these
reductive cancel culture on the public
square safe harbor
yes really hitting all the buzzwords
there
mike versus jesse ventura in a cage max
cage match hi from ireland what do you
think needs to happen for america's
image to be redeemed in the eyes of the
rest of the world get removing trump was
a good part of it getting vaccinated
would be a good part of it
thanks to men talk as well as brian boyd
who just gifted two subs putting us at
49.
eric krapf has just signed up with the
code
myhipa and thomas stebbings just signed
up putting us at 51
because we got to 50 we are going to
look at one more minute of the my pillow
interview we're doing a minute for every
10 subs this will be released at some
point in the future
at a round table event i never thought i
could come within a hundred yards of the
white house with my past
i see i see i see i see and here i here
i end up in the white house i said who's
sitting here
and they go the president is there's
like 15 of us in the room
first time i was in the white house and
and uh they do
that we go on national tv then it's just
him and i facing forward
and uh it went viral that that
screenshot and
all my friends are going what is this x
crack addict sitting next to the
president united states
jesus is real because this could not
happen this makes no sense right in
other words it's almost like
this mike lindell pillow guy
being at the white house makes such
little sense it must be divine
intervention
uh absolutely so it's just like when i
say oh
man when we when i went there uh
uh when we did start making mass we had
got a i got a uh
a letter from the white house saying
would you come in and uh all right so
there is minute number five there is
minute number five
um wow
uh what what an event so we're standing
by for joe biden continuing to stand by
at any point did you think about
referring to him as mike pillow i did
actually think of asking him you know
ceo and inventor of my pillow mike
lindell is so
uh it's so busy are you opposed to just
being called mike pillow and it just got
away
from me quite frankly daniel says is
this the most powerful nation
in the word yeah i think so
felix says would withdrawing all troops
from foreign soil
improve how the world views the u.s
maybe in the short term although medium
and long is
is more of a question mark i think
um i do have one
unban request that i'm going to
adjudicate right now with my
hammer um let's see here
a user named sushi nmh
showed up yesterday and said more covet
hysteria
covet is done delta isn't nearly as bad
as the original strain
so they're gonna have us all wearing
diapers on our face and sitting in our
houses again
while suicides and overdoses skyrocket
cool ban me i guess they were
banned and then their unban request is
you people are the problem that is a
permaban for
aggressive covetous get them out of here
get them off my stream
exactly too easy too easy
meanwhile by the way we'll get back to
pillow in a moment
um this is dr catherine o'neal
i don't know if you guys have seen
what's happening in louisiana
let me show you
okay see that that's louisiana
okay so that's a problem
that's a real problem in louisiana here
is a doctor in louisiana explaining
what's going on
when i left the hospital earlier there
were 23 patients on the board
waiting for a transfer into our hospital
for an icu bed
those are the ones that i looked at
first there's no reason to even look at
the med surg beds they're never going to
get here
but you look at every single one of
those icu beds and you spend
all day trying to figure out how you can
staff another one
those are 23 people sitting in an er
somewhere
many of those ers are not attached to a
hospital at all there is only an er
physician
many of those ers are attached to a
hospital that does not have a critical
care doctor
or a subspecialty cardiologist
or a subspecialty surgeon you have
people with chest pain
sitting in an er right now where their
families sit in the waiting room and
they are ringing their hands and they're
calling
everybody they know do you know somebody
who works at the lake can they get me in
do you know somebody who works at
ochsner can they get me in and they will
do that for days
and that patient will lose muscle they
will lose
years of their life but they will stay
in that er
because there are no more beds left
those 23 patients
are a glimpse of what we have been doing
for the last two weeks
while we have been trying to get
everybody vaccinated
and it's not helping enough because it's
not happening fast
enough and when you come inside our
walls
it is quite obvious to you that these
are
the darkest days of this pandemic we are
no longer giving adequate care to
patients
that is also stopped and you heard from
each of these physicians that we no
longer think we're giving adequate care
to anybody because these are the darkest
days of the pandemic
how do i get those patients to this
hospital how do i open beds
so the point is there's no they're
running out of room there's just there's
just no room there's not enough beds
there's too many patients not enough
beds
i mean look at this look at this is
louisiana right now
a very highly infected and lowly
vaccinated state
vaccination is going to get us there but
it will not get us there fast enough
we will lose right it's too late because
of it
they don't have room now but if we put
on our masks
as we've done through the last several
surges we will see a decrease
in hospitalizations again and that will
give us time
for the vaccinated to work those who got
vaccinated in the last two weeks already
have protection and i doubt that i will
ever see them in our hospital due to
cover 19.
and if you get vaccinated today and you
mask up i doubt that i'll ever see you
yesterday i drove down 190 which is one
of my favorite drives
and we got to see some rice being cut
which
my father's a farmer so that is one of
my favorite scenes
we drove behind some people who were
driving motorcycles and it was the end
of the day so it was tolerable
we drove past some kids who were on
their four-wheelers looked like they
were having a great time
usually that is an incredibly enjoyable
drive and all i could think about
was that i have seen people in
four-wheeler accidents and motorcycle
accidents
and farming accidents in the last two
weeks who sat in their ers in their
small towns those are my people
right understand this is such a key
point
if you say i i'm not going to get
vaccinated i'm unlikely to get sick with
covet and need help i don't care
okay if there are unvaccinated people
filling up the er if you get into a car
accident
there may be no room for you this is
such a critical point
it's such a fundamental point you have
an accident at work and go to the er
if it's full already with covet patients
how is that going to affect your
treatment right it's just an
absolutely brilliant point that she
makes
um and we'll look at maybe doing
something with that on the show that's
louisiana it's just a disaster there
disaster uh okay let's see if we've got
another minute
of uh mike pillow i wanna say thanks to
matthew lester for signing up on my
website joinpackman.com with the coupon
code myhipa
and katherine cox just signed up on my
website with the coupon code myhippa
that's 53.
i also want to say thanks to snowflake
warrior k
ferkic
odw zero page
fire pre instant classics
ron is twitching do for yuo
uh that's nine putting us at 62
which means we've got one more minute of
the mike pillow interview we'll go to
another minute at 70. cause we
started making mass we were one of the
first ones i believe in the country
and we get there and he's going to have
us all speak from the rose garden and
you have to have
pre-pre-approved remarks and
if i told you the whole story i mean
it's just uh it's divine how everything
went down even he's sitting in the front
row
right was things that couldn't happen
there was a a series of events happened
there
where i ended up being the only one on
stage with him and then
asked him if i could say something off
the cuff and flip this paper over and
then spoke out about
i remember i was getting back in the
word and and it uh
you know if you think there i mean i was
that was heard around the world i did
109 interviews in sev
in five days well mike listen
there's so many things i want to ask you
about let me do a few that are sort of
like shorter
things one is i don't know what he was
signaling to the entire interviews he
was displeased with something that was
going on and he kept signaling to
someone
um in terms of uh states that
were given to joe biden that you believe
donald trump won what what is the how
extensive is that list
it's huge okay so that now we're at
minute number so we're pausing that's
all we've gotten so far
we will do another minute of this when
we get to 70.
um oh wait we may be close
actually already nasty cues just
resubbed on twitch
man own eigenshaft just signed up
uh oh that's 64. okay all right very
good
so we got that news out of new york city
bill de blasio will mandate
covet vaccines for certain indoor
activities
this is super strong the order goes into
effect
august 16 with full enforcement on
september 13.
de blasio said the mandate known as the
key to nyc pass
would encourage increased immunizations
to combat the spread of the delta
coronavirus variant
the mayor's order comes a day after de
blasio mandated vaccines
for the city's new hires so here are the
rules
require new york city will require proof
of vaccination
for employees and customers of indoor
eateries
gyms and entertainment centers
this is happening in new york city
it includes gyms it includes restaurants
it includes presumably all sporting
events broadway
movie theaters etc the city will begin
inspecting businesses for compliance in
mid-september all affected customers and
workers
can either provide their vaccination
cards or upload proof
to the excelsior pass application
the national restaurant association
issued a statement
it expressed support but said the
mandate would be burdensome
and will result in significant changes
for restaurants moving forward checking
vaccination status isn't like an eye
like iding a customer before giving them
a drink
so anyway this is going to be a big deal
this is going to be a big deal but new
york city is doing it
extremely aggressively extremely
aggressively and we'll see where that
gets them
um a few other super chats here
i'm looking for baked goods from the
standpoint of tastiness
what level of support would you see as
the floor where you stop covering trump
rallies we're getting pretty close
what's the end game of desantis and
abbott type governors what do you think
who do you think they will spin it i
guess they mean how do you think they
will spin it
once the body bags start piling up i
don't know yet
i genuinely don't know yet i live in
louisiana
the cove denial is so bad here the
attorney general is telling people
how to avoid the mask mandate yeah
aaron says you have to see melissa
caronese vaccine
comments oh my rocket on twitter has the
video pinned
let's see
let's see what's up with that here we go
and just like stacy said
it's sterilizing people is this really
marissa carone or is this an actress i
actually can't tell does anybody know
i'm realizing i saw this the other day
and i thought it was an actress
is this really corrone
nobody knows all right
if you're around somebody who was
vaccinated
and in the past three weeks
and i actually don't know if it's really
her i mean her appearance is so bizarre
it seems different
it causes sterilization
it causes sterilization in children
young children
it's been shown to lower
girls egg counts lower boys sperm counts
it's a proven fact it's a proven fact
um planned parenthood is paying people
to go door to door
and push the vaccines why why planned
parenthood
could it be because
is that a wig i can't even tell what
looks different about her than before or
is it
i don't know is it it's i guess it's
really her who knows
okay all right well that's what's going
on there
i want to say thank you to um
adam spivey for signing up on my website
with the coupon code
myhipa i also want to say thanks to
a user just going by the name chinese
name i guess they think i'd have too
much trouble pronouncing it
who signed up with the coupon code
indictment 21. those are numbers 65 and
66.
over on twitch chameleon chuck neezy
cody john wayne slam drunk
head asso stikai
p villanueva have signed up that's one
two three four five
six seven putting us at 73
and getting us one more minute of pillow
talk with mike pillow
and it's absolutely huge and not that i
believe i know he wants i
because we have all the packet captures
and the data from the whole election
we'll get to that minnesota new
hampshire
um um all the swing states we talk about
nevada
um georgia michigan wisconsin
um arizona pennsylvania
yeah yeah uh i mean the big massive
dumpster
there are very few that biden were less
than ten you
at one point i heard you say you believe
trump even won california do you still
believe that
that that's that's correct and we're
going to reveal that at the cyber
symposium i'm happy these are going to
be
we actually will have the data to back
that up what's the math of le just to
pick one mike
for people to understand california has
22 million registered voters
10 million are democrats and there's
five million republicans
how did trump win california i didn't
say
one for sure we're going to reveal that
the symposium let's use minnesota
okay the zavosium at the supposed
zavozium he's going to reveal it all
right
so there's another minute there
um yeah if people so we'll keep doing a
minute for every every 10 uh subs
he did say he won and then he says well
i don't know about for sure it's all
really really weird
uh let's see here hold on a second where
did normal guy go
normal guy oh david sir will you ever
share
spanish content from encontex well
that's that was a show just during the
election
and i shared some interviews and the
show's been over for many months so
probably
we've probably shared everything we're
going to on the youtube channel
texas the surge in cases and working for
a public school is a massive pain
two weeks till classes start and board
already said no masks
not to mention abbott the dread is real
so sad it's crazy what's going on in
some states
pym tool says via super chat the left
got two left so i joined the far right
sounds weird another message from pim
tool who says a sad reality is that
areas with low rates of vaccination
south have the highest rates of obesity
diabetes heart disease and smoking
horrible mix
daniel says sir your wife is up in the
air
yes exactly sir your wife is up in the
air
aaron says it's really corrone she's
running for office in my state she goes
on to say the vaccine makes your eyes
glow so they can pupil scan
and separate unvaxed wow
make sinking city pre-natural man-made
farm
don't even know what that means trump
won california and cats have taken over
control of nuclear weapons in the united
states
yeah it seems unlikely to me what's the
best way to deal with conspiracy nuts
without going into an online war of
words
this is obviously going out of control
yeah i don't know that there's any
advantage to engaging with conspiracy
nuts in a casual way like on facebook
and stuff like that just doesn't doesn't
make any any sense to me
makes no sense to me i want to say thank
you to michelle
schultz who just signed up at
joinpacman.com with the coupon code
myhipa
today we have a perfect combination of
things we have the coupon code myhippa
which saves you 70 percent
and we have an interview i did just
hours ago with mike lindell which has
not been released the only place where
you can see it is i'm playing
one minute at a time on the show today
so we're six
memberships away from getting
another minute so to speak it's all
pretty illegal yeah these
it's it's pretty crazy andre thomas also
signed up at joinpakman.com
and his new member number 75.
let me play a few voicemails for people
people yesterday really seem to be
liking the voicemails
let's just play a couple of them we
don't have to go crazy
um here's one
hi david this is adamson connecticut um
i know underwater guys i just i just
can't deal with it
hi gabriella family all cancer survivors
will apologize
any time i call sometimes i have long
notice
then from michigan um i'm watching you
enjoy your show i like the facts
i have a question now that the doj is
coming
out about the truth about trump
and his alleged um
miss abuse of the office is it possible
that he should
we can go back and you teach him nah
it's not gonna happen
i understand the i understand it's but
it's not going to happen
um okay let's
let's look at listen to a couple others
hello david
we love listening to you every morning
we record it at night listen to it in
the morning and it's so
you're charismatic i love the way you
talk about everything
wow we're retired i'm 74 my wife's 71
and we uh haven't followed politics till
recently and you've really made that
a pleasant thing to listen to
i appreciate that very very much
david sir recently we've been seeing a
resurgence
of clips of joe biden and carmel harris
talking about the skepticism for the
vaccine under
the trump administration and
anti-vaxxers are using this
as kind of a platform to say see it's
not just us
i wonder if you could compare and
contrast these as part of a segment
love the show thank you very much have
done it in fact have done it
and uh it's it's pretty strong
um yeah we've talked about that quite a
bit please please check out uh
if you should i mean just search kamala
vaccine probably on my youtube channel
and you would find it
i think we're going to have ourselves
another minute of mike pillow clinton
peck just signed up at jointpakman.com
axel solis just signed up cameron train
just signed up and jennifer beltran just
signed up putting us at 79 we then have
jeff builds a base light cloud snowflake
warrior
elora like noodles who signed up via
twitch putting us at 83
giving us an additional minute of mike
pillow
my home state well they are here they
are losing minnesota by a hundred
thousand votes now
i went around all over everyone say oh
minneapolis and
all we only have like two big cities
duluth and minneapolis
this is when i start to take just a
horrified
uh look on my face as just the default
paul
and it's all democrats supposedly right
and all our northern minnesota democrats
well that's that's the past everybody
that democrat that ship
sailed those were traditional democrats
a lot of them
and minnesota the actual number
minnesota one donald trump won by 65.
people asking why i'm wearing the same
shirt this was recorded 90 minutes ago
it's
it's the same day i didn't change
between before the stream a thousand
and we will show this too at this
symposium yeah this is facts these are
facts
and how did that happen because uh it
doesn't matter where you the
the past everything changed with donald
trump people
people are voting i believe people are
voting for they want politicians that
are for the people
that think you know and donald trump did
stuff for all people if you get to our
great
this great place where we're in in
december of 2019
i think everyone whether you're a
democrat or republican
realizes that all right so we're doing a
minute at a time this is my interview
with mike pillow this took place just a
couple you know hour and a half ago
every 10 subs we are releasing another
minute um i want to say thanks to nathan
schenken who just signed up at
joinpackman.com with the coupon code
myhipa
very exciting um yeah my approach
in the in the pillow interview was to
pretend to be taking him
seriously and it took a while for him to
realize i don't believe a thing he's
saying and
at the end of the interview he
eventually says that he recognizes that
i mocked something he said
um but i we we played it very straight
with them
and i think i don't know that he
necessarily knew
my perspective on uh on on things thanks
to angie lowe
and rhino inverse for the twitch subs
putting us at 86. we'll do another
minute of this when we get to 90 and
that
that may be happening soon it may not um
mike pillow should be illegal he is a
political weapon of mass destruction
yes uh slow down
sinking cities land we can manipulate
into farms that be under water
okay spencer smith says sorry joined
late why did he agree to the interview
i have no idea i don't know
will you be attending president obama's
60th birthday party will you bring a
gift yes i am going to the obama
birthday party in edgartown
uh on martha's vineyard beautiful love
martha's vineyard
um i will be probably i'll take the
chappie fairy
over and back and then go over to edgar
town
and i'll probably bring flan honestly
flan with dulce de leche just
something nice in argentinian haley says
despite the constant negative press
cobb fes
um these people will tell you the
vaccine is useless jewish conspiracy
over a fried pork chop sandwich and
their four lunch beers to stave off the
shakes
yeah that's aggressive
david i think you missed my super chat
saki said a cuomo statement is incoming
today what do you think it will be
no idea at all no idea whatsoever
couldn't tell you
i feel like i'm going to see the
governors of teas that must be texas and
florida on an episode of scooby-doo as
the dastardly duo
that very well may be thanks to
juan wick as well as iremen slim
90 gave out five subs
that's seven and kiki fast
signed up that's number eight putting us
at 94.
and 94 gets us a ninth minute of pillow
those things that that month that was a
manifestation of a of a couple years of
decisions being made by politicians
i.e donald trump and that by me and
those common sense decisions
that made here's a problem here's the
solution how would help people
all people not just their party or a
personal agenda
and that's what and we've seen that we
that was it was just awesome that
everyone in this country
got to experience that what what
political decisions we could
could manifest to and man everything was
great that we had
highest consumer confidence lowest gas
prices lowest
um uh unimposed unemployment i mean the
list goes on and on
yeah stock market i mean across the
board those were because of political
decisions everybody i
i want to focus in on the election piece
just so we we kind of keep
to keep that path forward there are some
like marjorie taylor green
who while she believes there were
problems with the election
she says trump is not coming back yeah
okay so that so i actually get into that
and i start challenging him a little bit
i slowly went into sort of telling him
what he's saying isn't making any sense
so we start we start to get
into that you know the thing i didn't
ask and i actually regret this i see
somebody put something about bamboo
fibers
as we were going i was trying to think
of a way to crowbar in
you know mike um a lot of different
people are focusing on different aspects
like for example bamboo fibers in
arizona do you think that
bamboo fibers um various sauces and
condiments
on ballots is any of it indicative of
anything relevant to who won the
election i wasn't able to
i just wasn't able to squeeze it in
there was no sensible way but i wanted
to do that
david vallar says isn't the fraud it
designed to help trump raise money while
he dangles the results like jesus's
second coming yeah essentially
essentially um i want to say
thank you to amber hussein for signing
up with the coupon code myhippa on my
website
also simon dreyfuss just signed up new
members number 95 and 96.
uh very much appreciate that putting us
at 96 and we will have another minute of
the mike pillow interview when we get
if and when we get to 100. did you ask
about elements of voting machines i
straight up asked him if he has voting
machines in his possession
and he did answer that comes up later in
the interview
do you think justice stems threatening
to blow up the infrastructure bill due
to cutting key parts will result in
blaming progressives or a better bill
i had no idea i have no i haven't heard
anything it's been years since i've even
heard the term justice democrats what
can somebody explain what they're doing
what are just and justice democrats as
an organization
yeah i just don't know
um diva says even mild covid can
can cut infections have caused permanent
erectile dysfunction
and compromise testosterone levels in
males of all ages
this data could be used to raise npi
vaccination rates in stubborn men
sure whatever
um i think that that's great
any way we can convince them thanks to
professor
x for signing up via twitch prime number
97
let's listen to a few more voicemails
because they are um they're coming in
fast and furious
yeah mr david i don't know what happened
i couldn't watch your last stream but
i'm i'm getting this
um so yeah i'm sorry for the message i
didn't drink i quit drinking a couple
weeks ago and then
my landlord had told us that we got to
find places to live because he's selling
because
i mean everything on the north west side
of chicago so everything's gentrified
everything
everything's going up you know what i
mean everyone they're buying up all the
properties and putting all these nice
ass apartment complexes up and [ __ ]
oh yeah all the poor people are getting
[ __ ] now right excuse my language
um okay so there's
there's that hello david pakman this is
my name is andrew i'm from
uh southwest missouri uh we're actually
kind of a
pretty bad covert hot spot at the moment
and i was just calling because i'm i'm
someone who
tends to lean left center left i'd say
and
i just the i think people underestimate
the level of programming that people
have
in rural america especially what i see
here where
people are rabidly
uh disbelieving of any logical
points especially when it comes to kobe
but also just apps
okay i think i think i get the point hi
david
have you ever considered having mike
lindell on for a weekly spot on the show
that's from last week that's funny
that's from last week and yet
here we have an interview with mike
pillow uh yeah
so we filmed an interview today we're
releasing a minute at a time
every 10 uh sign ups why not
um the full thing will be will be
released soon we're still figuring it
out
i don't think i have the uh energy to
have them on daily
woody underwood says i'd appreciate it
if you play my voice messages
popsicle stick and tape rather use them
and be alive
pac-man versus crowder let's go i think
mike pillow probably wouldn't stay
centered because
he wanted everyone to see the picture of
jesus behind him former evangelical here
that could be that certainly could be
thanks to thomas stebbings who just
signed up on my website with the coupon
code
myhipa also thanks to nugrangler for
signing up gifting a subscription via
twitch prime
and then putting us at 100 getting us
another minute you know what since we
got to 100 i'll do two minutes for every
10 now
is thomas johnson number 100 we're now
doing
two minutes of pillow for every 10. it
is false hope to believe he will be
reinstated you've said august or
september
do you still believe that and what's the
mechanism
a hundred percent i believe that yeah
she's she's misconstrued i mean they all
these
this is uh here's there's a couple
things here um
we're having the cyber symposium after
that that's august 10th 11th and 12th
everybody's going to watch this it's i
want it to be the biggest watched event
in history
yep billion people you watch that and
you're going to see
the packet captures and data from the
whole election this is non-subjective
evidence
everybody it's what i've had for months
now and i've been trying to get the word
out but i keep let's just cancel mike
lindell in my pillow
i've been trying to get the word out now
this gets out
we've had it ready for the supreme court
it's called a quo warranto
we bring that to the supreme court and
everyone says well they're not going to
bring back donald trump yes they are
here's why
so hold on mike i want to i want to hear
it but i want to make sure the audience
doesn't miss
it the supreme court is the mechanism
that will bring them back you're saying
there's there's more than one but i'm
giving you the first one okay okay
the easiest one okay okay the easiest
one
this when we get through the cyber
symposium which everybody needs to tell
everybody to watch this is so important
because these nine supreme court
justices they're people too
they've lived the american dream they
have families they have children
grandchildren
friends family they need to everyone
everyone
needs to watch this because it shows
that this was an attack by china
on our country it doesn't matter if
you're a democrat or republican
i said on jimmy kimmel i said jimmy said
if it was reverse mike would you do the
same thing
absolutely i would this is an attack on
our country
so what happens is in our country's
history
every elected official everyone
that you find out later there was a
crime committed i.e election fraud
the real winner gets put back in it's
happened
every single election now that's never
happened at the presidential level
okay so there we are two more minutes of
the pillow interview
it is 28 minutes long if you can believe
it he really gave me
plenty of time i don't know what he's
talking about by the way people are
saying
that they don't understand that i don't
under i did the interview and i don't
underst i don't know what he's talking
about i have no idea
no idea whatsoever thanks to theo
steinmiller for signing up with the
coupon code myhipa
also thanks to ryan biela for signing up
on my website with the coupon code
myhipa
lastly thanks to mr major bacon number
103
appreciate the sign it took him about 26
of the 28 minutes
for him to realize i was trolling
trolling him
woody underwood says your questions of
mike pillow violated hippo
and giraffe and gazelle i would even say
david has anyone checked mike liddell's
head for bamboo shoot
right right no that's a good point
few other uh voicemails
let's see what else we've got hello
david
my name is indigo noguera i'm based in
tucson arizona
the reason i'm calling is i mean i know
you said you don't like to talk about
future elections
but there's some concerns i have the
of the potential 2024 candidates
on the republican side the people that
worry me the most to be honest
are mike pompeo and tom cotton and
honestly
i'm worried that if one of them becomes
the president
uh we will uh slide into a militarized
christianized fascism
listen at this point we don't even know
that those people are running so it's
like i think it makes sense to be
like trump clearly would love to run if
he could win
and what happens in 22 will influence
that so there's some relevance
people that have not even indicated
they're running or even
plan to run or want to i just i don't
know that i have anything to say about
that right now
let's listen to the next voicemail what
it's worth let me register my opinion on
on this anti-vac sympathy this reddit
poll that you're citing which i did not
participate in
but i think you probably know what i'm
gonna fall that's right
i fall on the side of no no sympathy and
they got
they deserve what they get coming to him
and why is that david
it's because number one i don't know
them personally
if i know them personally like a
neighbor of mine i might
fall in the category below that the one
where i say no
but i don't wish him death uh and here's
why
because we are not approaching a
crossroads in this country
we've already passed the crossroads we
are now at the precipice
and desperate times call for desperate
people
actually could be the other way around
isn't it desperate times call for
desperate measures
i don't even know what that's about
david i was
recently watching a video of you talking
to destiny online
about wanting to get back into i guess
debating
um and my wife heard it and she thinks
that destiny
sounds like ben shapiro i would love
your reaction to this
i don't know about that i mean maybe
maybe there's something there i'm not
sure
uh yeah i don't know hi david i just
wanted to call
and talk about um the mask mandates
i'm all for wearing masks it's fine
i've been vaccinated i got vaccinated in
the first round in december
so i'm i'm fine however i
my issue with this new possible
you know blanket of mass mandates i kind
of feel a little irritated that
i feel like at some point in time when
are we gonna go ahead and turn around
and say
now it's personal responsibility yeah
you know i i've talked about this a
contro
a whole bunch of times um i i don't know
um it's uh yeah i just
i it's personal responsibility but at
the same time what we do affects others
we had the video earlier from this uh
doctor in louisiana who explained
if you get in a car accident um
you i might not have room for you even
though you might have done all the right
things because of all the coveted people
so it's it's
it's not as simple as personal
responsibility it's just not not quite
so simple
hey david i'm not drunk i just sound
like it
late at night and i'm calling you to
tell you
is this eric the actor from the grave i
have a
nine minute message you can't use on
your show
i'm wondering if the next uh
the next um sign up bonus will be my
sharona
because you already used the other one
anyway
have a good night
no i'm not drunk or high either all
right so there it is
a super strong super strong statement
there
uh let's see what else is going on here
oh sorry are we doing another two
minutes of my pillow shay b
just signed up via twitch prime putting
us at 104.
adt chemistry is 105.
chris shella barger just signed up on my
website
so did alan delgado and richard russell
putting us at 108 all right so we're
almost at another two minutes of pillow
um let's see what else we've got here
mr pac-man thanks so much for taking my
call i'm calling because um
i i heard your your interview with nick
and julie
regarding um millennials in terms of
their ability to accumulate um
what wealth um retaining financial
financial stability and also dealing
with issues like
student debt and it reminds me of
something that that i remember reading
on a hill and i wanted to ask
ask you about that um i'm curious what
you think about
um students who decided
you decided to not pay their student
loans
there's an um college finance reports
that 35
of students who are in debt stop paying
repaying or clear loans and
the reasoning okay yeah that's that's
super specific i would i would probably
have to think about that
a little bit say hello my name is billy
and they was wondering uh
uh you know uh how do you feel about the
delta variant
and uh you know me and my family we went
on down and got dumped
what on earth
but uh we're worried about this delta
valley so i was wondering what you
thought about it mr park parkman so
you helped us out they immediately
called right back
hi this is at crimsontide at twitter.com
and uh i was just wondering uh oh i'm
from north carolina uh
and uh i was wondering uh how you felt
about the
eviction moratorium and uh how if
biden drops the ball on this we're
probably i mean
we're probably pretty screwed for 2022 i
reckon
he may be making an announcement about
that momentarily in fact
uh thank you to lil john 619 for the
twitch sub number 109 today
few other super chats coming in the
previous caller was clearly derek from
texas right it wasn't eric the actor it
was derek from texas
sir remind people you have to re-up
twitch prime yeah it doesn't
automatically happen you have to re-up
it desperate times call for unhinged
interviews
did pillow reveal trump's beautiful
health plan
he did not actually what's better sell
to uniform or buy
uniform i don't know what that means
biden to announce new eviction
moratorium 60 days 90
coverage i don't know if that's true but
that's interesting
bay photo says if trump is reinstated
i'll sue for hipaa and hippo
kyle says look like you turned into
tucker for a second there
billy is a prank audio from ownage
pranks
now i don't know what that is you got me
i don't know what that is
thanks to christopher rides a bike we
are now at 110
new members today and that gets us
another couple minutes of the mike
pillow interview right that's the only
difference
so there is precedence but also you you
combine this precedence
this was a very very very uh it's a it's
an act of war basically as wow
they've attacked us and the democrats
warned us this everybody
they warned us from my senator amy
klobuchar to kamala heroes
they all warned us about this cyber
attack why can't any of them say kamala
about going through the machines and
taking our country without guns
and uh they just happen to use the
democrat party so no matter who you are
we go back to now the warrant the
supreme court's gonna get this
yeah uh we're gonna give a probably late
august and now what they do with it i'm
not the supreme court
but they'll have some options they might
put you know pull it down and put donald
trump in right away because his evidence
is non-subjective
i see or or because all the down tickets
were affected too
many many down tickets maybe the supreme
court i'm just putting out there has a
whole new election
wow well how could we have a new
election
right with these with these machines we
can't
but at the symposium on the 10th 11th
and 12th of august
members live streamed on frank's speech
worldwide of course
and worldwide prank speech.com we're
going to live stream at 72 hours
straight
we're going to unveil a replacement for
the machines
and everyone says well mike are you
going to do that now you're going to
show this
is just a money thing so you can make
money no we're giving the technology
away to all companies
okay okay but so to one i want to go one
thing because there's so much here my
head is virtu
it's literally spinning here mike um
just to show how
confident you are that this
reinstatement would happen
would you want to make a financial bet
with me on it because i just don't see
it and i want to prove to people just
how confident you are
would you want to put 25 000 up against
me on
all right what do you think he says you
think he takes the bet you guys think he
bets me what do you what do people think
huh what do you think does he
does he bet me is he so confident
thanks to black white rook by the way
for the twitch sub does he bet me the 25
grand
also thanks to uh chris from uh uh chris
from work
number 112 today um
thanks to kirk alexander for signing up
on my website with the what do people
think does mike pillow take the bet
let's just back it up a little bit here
all right here we go for the machines
and evelyn says well mike are you going
to do that now you're going to show this
is just a money thing so you can make
money
no we're giving the technology away to
all companies
okay okay but so to one i want to go one
thing because there's so much here my
head is virtu
is literally spinning here mike um just
to show how
confident you are that this
reinstatement would happen
would you want to make a financial bet
with me on it because i just don't see
it and i want to prove to people just
how confident you are
would you want to put 25 000 up against
me on it that by the end of september
trump is reinstated one of my addictions
was gambling
ah but not but i will tell you this i
put up
five million dollars
so the answer is no guys he doesn't take
the bet because he has a problem with
gambling
he has a problem with gambling okay guys
um
no deal no deal you should have known
you should have known that was uh quite
predictable
quite predictable i must say i want to
say thanks to richard rangel who just
signed up at joinpackman.com
putting us at 114 we will release
another two minutes at the 120 mark
um now that's true it's not gambling if
it's a hundred percent right it's sort
of like
if i say i'll bet you the sun comes up
tomorrow it's not a hundred percent but
it's pretty damn close
it's not really a gamble in that sense
that's an interesting point
david my mom says
talking about me i introduced her to
your channel after she mentioned having
difficulty separating truth from fiction
on youtube great job very much
appreciate that
love it uh david what the hell is mike
the pillow guy talking about
i have no idea david deepak pakman host
of the david pakman show sure
did mike offer you your own pillow
discount code he did not
he did not i don't think he was um
i don't think he was that eager to have
me selling pillows
here's a new caller who called one two
three four four times in a row could be
something let's see
hey david it is steven eckhart again uh
just giving you my daily phone call
um just wanted to let you know um i'm
openly challenging
any left-wing debater to a
debate i am not a right-winger i am far
left in fact i believe i live left while
other people just talk about it
um i would like to debate tyt but they
are
very much dodging me after the crowder
they're dodging him for debacle my
senses tyt has no idea who this guy is
where no one would develop or crowd or
wouldn't devout
debate cedar because cedar's too small
for him
there's no reason my little channel
shouldn't debate
i think chris vosh wants to debate this
guy so then he called right back again
so i'm sorry stephen eckhart one more
time i just want to finish these things
i'm saying is like
you know the shirts that you wear you
actually advertise and prop
up that company i don't know if it is or
if it isn't but
is that recycled materials
what what on earth
oh my god you could do that
you know you can wear recycled clothes i
might just wear a trash bag actually
and make the choice yourself in your own
life as david pakman to do the things
that i can tell you that are simple
in your own life to make the change i
don't see
one left wing host doing that i'm
actually i'm currently weaving pants
from all the bamboo fibers that they're
pulling off the ballots in the arizona
ardet
the humanist report do you know how much
petroleum goes into the tattoos that he
has
that can't be real oh my god
i'm gonna have to talk to mike from uh
from humanist report this guy's the best
the petroleum footprint of his of his
tattoos
oh my god that cannot be real
please clip it guys that is something
else
um let's i can't tell if this is real
let's see a little bit more
like is that not vanity it is bro
all of those things are well my tattoo
carbon footprint is zero i have no
tattoos
that are causing the resources to be
sucked dry off of this planet
every lady who puts on makeup every
single day that's petrol-based doesn't
want to take responsibility for the
soldier that dies across seas
stop putting makeup on your face men
stop
making these women feel like they have
to put makeup on their face
so this is getting really edgy so then
he immediately called
right back hey david last message in
message three the last thing i want to
say is
i will go to a tyt live chat and i will
say what i just told you
and they silenced me on that channel
well if it's it's like 10 pages to
transcribe it is like 10 pages it
probably was a wall of text you wouldn't
stop
we'd have to do the same thing i am the
left
that is a problem dude huge problem and
also why are you calling me about tyt i
have nothing to do with uoit
it'll release silence me i follow every
tos rule i am never disrespectful i am
literally
nicer than dan bailey was to tucker
carlson to these people with the
exception
of saying i will decimate them in a
debate that's it and that's not
bandworthy we all know it's not
so what i'm trying to get at here is
what happens
when they do that so i don't feel
comfortable on a left-wing channel i
can't
say what i feel and it's
hold on what happened there communicated
from a left-wing channel
so what happens to people like that like
where am i left to go
you know like this is how you push
people to the right
is because i literally look at it and go
wow the left
i don't know what is is he saying that
as a left winger who's mad at left
wingers he's not allowed to chat
and so now everybody's on the right as a
result at all
they do not want to listen to me where
is my choice to go
to the right is that what they really
want they you know
it's hard to look at yourself and go you
know what man
i i should do this man i'm gonna do that
you know what tomorrow is david pakman
i'm gonna buy a recycled shirt
wear it on the air and prop it up that's
it
that's all we got to do man it is not
hard
you know listen to the real left we are
the minuscule portion of this world and
the problem is
there is propaganda all right and then
he promised that was his last call but
he did call back
again with a full three-minute call
sorry david stephen eckert one more time
just
i can discuss these things with you
calmly we can have this discussion on
air
i wasn't getting that impression be the
way i am in the last few messages what
is there even to discuss you know
it's the frustration of being shunned by
a left-wing site and feeling like you
have nowhere to go with the real
information um i just you know
really need you to know that we have to
have this discussion on air
we have to get to the bottom of these
issues and make people accountable on an
individual level
we just cannot sit around and wait for
policy man
it's not getting the job done and the
point of this last message is
man tyt's moderators are calling me a
paid
right-wing troll dude it's like who
they're moder i can't have
but i have nothing to do with tyt or
tyt's moderators i have no way to
adjudicate any of what is being said it
has nothing to do with my show it's just
like come on guys please
please um
by the way this is a funny contrast to
that last one
hey david um have you ever considered
just doing away with the voicemails on
the show
i'm thinking about it right now actually
why it's interesting you should bring
that up i'm that it's it's
it just occurred to me um
i just thought of it is there any way to
reach those who
choose to follow trump how can they be
fooled by this obvious con man
i don't know enrique says hi dad got
coveted 62.
damaged his heart now has heart failure
needs to get a pacemaker yes
i'm pissed off at these right wingers
clowns sorry to hear that
imagine calling to virtue signal a
youtube sponsor youtuber sponsors
hey david maybe you should wear a paper
bag over your head like shia labeouf
while doing your show is it la buff or
laboof
anybody know
nobody knows okay that's fine whoa here
we go joe biden all right
big announcement coming
mast safely masked good afternoon
last week i laid out what we needed to
do to beat the covet 19 by
pandemic and the challenges posed by the
delta
variant this is a very different variant
than what we've dealt with previously
it's highly transmissible and it's
causing a new wave of cases
it accounts for over 80 percent of all
cova 19 cases in the united states today
experts tell us that we're going to see
these cases rise in the weeks ahead
a largely preventable tragedy that will
get worse before it gets better
what's different about this surge from
previous ones
is we have the tools to prevent this
rise in cases
from shutting down our businesses our
schools our society
as we saw what happened last year while
cases are on the rise it's important to
note
we've not seen a comparable rise in
hospitalizations or deaths
in most areas of the country in most
that's because 165 million americans are
fully
vaccinated including 80 percent of the
most vulnerable
americans our seniors and the best line
of defense against the delta vex
the virus is the vaccine it's as simple
as that
period the vaccine
i want to be crystal clear about what's
happening in the country today
we have a pandemic of the unvaccinated
now i know there's a lot of
misinformation out there so i have
people telling me to turn off the closed
captioning
and to turn it on so i don't know what
to do guys highly unlikely to get coven
19.
and even if you do the chances are you
won't show any symptoms
and if you do they'll most likely be
very mild
vaccinated people almost never are
hospitalized with covet 19.
in fact according to one recent study 95
of of overall covet 19 hospitalizations
are among those
not fully vaccinated and the data shows
that virtually
all the cases hospitalizations and
deaths
due to covet 19 are from the
unvaccinated population
last month a study showed that over 99
of covet 19 deaths have among have been
among the
unvaccinated people 99
that means if you're unvaccinated you
are much more likely to
one get covert 19 2 get hospitalized and
3
die if you get it this is a tragedy
people are dying and will die who don't
have to die
the data is absolutely clear as i've
said
we have a pandemic of the unvaccinated
think of it this way 191 million
americans have gotten at least one shot
including 70 percent of adults over the
age of 18.
165 million americans are fully
vaccinated but about 90 million
americans are eligible for vaccines
and still haven't gotten their first
shot
you know i think there's a clear link
between the lowest vaccine
i know i don't think actually the lowest
vaccinated states
and the states are the highest case
rates
this past week the most vaccinated state
in america vermont
has seen just five new cases five
per day of covet 19 for every 100
000 people who live in that state
that means on any given day only 30
people
in the entire state of vermont got
coveted 19.
nearby maine which has vaccinated almost
80 percent of their adults
has seen just six new cases per hundred
thousand
but the state with the lowest
vaccination rates are seeing
ten to twenty times as many new cases
per hundred thousand people
it's moving like wildfire through the
unvaccinated community
and it's heartbreaking particularly
because it's preventable
that's why we're doing everything we can
to get more people vaccinated
and we're seeing real results in the
past two weeks we've seen a 55
increase in the average number of new
people
getting vaccinated every day that's good
in the last seven days alone nearly
three million americans have gotten
their first shot
that's the highest seven day total in a
month
importantly over the past two weeks the
eight states with the highest current
case rates
have seen a doubling of the number of
people newly vaccinated each day
the message is getting through
apparently louisiana has seen
a 212 percent increase in the average
number of newly vaccinated people
in that state per day going from
600 to over 11 000 people vaccinated per
day
arkansas is up 99 mississippi is up 125
alabama is up 186
going from 3200 to 9150 people
vaccinated
per day this will make a big difference
these are encouraging signs we have to
continue our
aggressive efforts to vaccinate the
unvaccinated
last week i announced additional steps
to incentivize americans to get
vaccinated
including calling on states to offer a
hundred dollars
for anyone willing to step up and get a
vaccination shot
you know and already minnesota
and new mexico have done that north
carolina announced its 100 day incentive
his hundred dollar
incentive today places that have offered
the hundreds out of the hundred thousand
a hundred dollars that'd be really good
i'd go back and get vaccinated three
times
but all kidding aside offered the
hundred dollars to get vaccination
have seen an uptick of 25 percent and
daily vaccination rates
we also announced that small and
medium-sized businesses
will be fully reimbursed for offering
paid time off for their employees to get
vaccinated
and for them to take a child or a parent
to get vaccinated
and i announced some tough sometimes
unpopular steps to keep people safe in
our
and our economy strong all federal
workers
must report their vaccination status or
be subject to strict requirements
any federal worker who does not attest
to their vaccination status
or is not vaccinated will require to
mask no matter where they work
test once or twice a week socially
distance and generally will not be
allowed to travel for work
wow i directed my administration to take
steps to apply similar standards to all
federal contractors
if you want to do business with federal
government get your workers vaccinated
i also directed the pentagon to look at
adding covet 19 to the list of
vaccinations that are required
for our troops because the others are
required
i approve the department of veterans
affairs to require doctors nurses and
other healthcare workers
who care for our veterans to be
vaccinated
and the good news is that now many are
following the federal government's lead
in the past several days states and
local officials have come out to impose
similar vaccination mandates and the
private sector is stepping up as well
even fox says vaccination requirements
even fun walmart google netflix disney
tyson foods for the recent actions
requiring vaccination for employees
look i know this isn't easy but i will
have their backs
in the backs of other private public
sector leaders
if they take such steps
but other but others have declined to
step up
i find it disappointing and worst of all
some state officials are passing laws or
signing orders
that forbid people from doing the right
thing
a lot of people getting banned by the
way seven states not only ban
mask mandates but also ban them in their
school districts
even for young children who cannot get
vaccinated
some states have even banned businesses
and universities from requiring workers
and students to be masked or vaccinated
and the most extreme
of those measures is like the one in
texas that say state universities or
community colleges
could be fined if it allows a teacher to
ask her
unvaccinated students to wear a mask
what are we doing covet 19 is a national
challenge
and it must come together we have to
come together all of us together
as a country to solve it make no mistake
the less the excellent the ex excuse me
the escalation
of cases is particularly concentrated in
states with low
vaccination rates just two states
florida and texas account for one-third
of all new covet-19 cases in the entire
can you imagine
just two states look we need leadership
from everyone
and some governors aren't willing to do
the right thing to beat this pandemic
then they should allow businesses and
universities who want to do the right
thing to be able to do it
i say to these governors please help
but you aren't going to help at least
get out of the way
the people are trying to do the right
thing
use your power to save lives
i've made it our first and top priority
to have
a vaccine available for every single
american from the day i got elected
that was my priority let me be clear
we have a supply for every single
american
and that will never change at the same
time
it's also in our national interest to
share some of our vaccines with the
world
please which gets me to the second thing
i want to discuss today
from the beginning of my presidency i've
been very clear-eyed
that we need to attack this virus
globally not just at home
because it's an america's self-interest
to do so
the virus knows no boundaries you can't
build a wall high enough to keep it out
there's no wall high enough for ocean
wide enough
to keep us safe from the vaccine another
from the
cove 19 in other countries in fact
just like the original virus that caused
covet 19
the delta variant came from abroad
as long as the virus continues to raise
out rage outside the united states
potentially more dangerous variants
could arrive at our shores again
we know the covet 19 in other countries
stifles economic growth disrupts supply
chains
risks instability and weakness of
governments
as we've seen in the united states the
key to growing economies is to
vaccinate people so just as the american
economy is recovering
it's in all of our interest to have
global be a global economy
begin to recover as well this is about
our values
we value inherent dignity of all people
the inherent dignity of everyone
in times of trouble americans reach out
to offer a helping hand
that's who we are i've said before
in the fight against covet 19 the united
states is committed
to be the arsenal of vaccines just as we
were
the arsenal democracy during world war
ii
we're backing up that commitment we've
contributed
more than any other nation to kovacs
the collective global efforts delivering
covet 19 vaccines across the world
we've supported manufacturing efforts
abroad
through our partnerships with japan
india australia
known as the quad during my trip to
europe in june
i announced the united states has
purchased a groundbreaking
500 million doses of pfizer and then
donate them those doses
nearly to a nearly 100 low and
middle-income countries who don't have
the vaccine
those doses will start to ship at the
end of this month
we also announced that we donate 80
million doses of our own vaccine to
supply the war which has already begun
and today
i have an important update we've already
exceeded
80 million doses that have been gone out
as of today the united states has
shipped over 110 million doses
of u.s vaccines to 65 countries that are
among the hardest hit in the world
let me say it again as of today
we have shipped over 110 million doses
to 65 nations
according to the united nations this is
more than the donations of all
24 countries that have donated any
vaccine to other countries
including china and russia all those
nations combined
these vaccine donations from america are
free
we're not selling them there are no
demands no conditions no coercion
attached
and there's no favoritism and no strings
attached
we're doing this to save lives and to
end this pandemic
that's it in fact we're donating
vaccines to countries that have real
issues
we have real issues with and will
continue to give
tens of millions of the doses away
across the summer
and work to increase u.s manufacturing
and manufacturing
of vaccines around the world as well
it's not just vaccines we're continuing
to provide countries with
uh in need with more testing protective
equipment
and personnel to stem the surge of the
virus
we've done it in india and elsewhere let
me close with this
i've said before in the race for the
21st century between democracy
and autocracies we need to prove
that democracies can deliver and the
democracies of the world are looking to
america to lead again
in two ways first to demonstrate we can
control this virus at home
and second to show we can help address
it around the world
vaccinate america and help vaccinate the
world
that's how we're about to beat this
thing
we're always going to have enough doses
for every american who wants one
our work in donating vaccines of the
world is about america following through
on our promises
and delivering what we say will deliver
and showing how american science and
technology
american business and academia and our
government can all work together
above all it's proving democracies can
deliver
and yet again that america is back
leading in the world
not by the example of our power but by
the power of our example
right we still have a lot of work to do
so if you're unvaccinated please please
please get the shot
but just don't take it from me just read
the news
listen to the voices of the unvaccinated
patients in the hospital
they're spending the most powerful
message
to their families and everyone around
the world a powerful message to
everybody
as they're lying in bed many dying from
kova 19 they're asking doc can i get the
vaccine
the doctors have to look them down and
say no sorry it's too late
right now too many people are dying are
watching a loved one dying and saying
if i just got vaccinated if i
jest folks
this isn't about politics the virus
doesn't care if you're a democrat or
republican
this is about life and death life and
death i can't say it any more plainly
than this
the vaccine saves lives and it could
save yours or your child's
you know i know we can do this we're the
united states of america
we're prepared like never before we have
the tools and the resources to save
lives at home and around the world
this is who we are this is what we do
this is why there's no nation like us on
earth
god bless you all and may god protect
our troops
now it takes a few questions
i have a question for you on coronavirus
but first i'd like to start with the
news of the day given
back in march you said that if the
investigation confirmed the allegations
against governor cuomo
then he should resign so will you now
call on him
i'm calling for him to resign peter said
the 11 women were credible
i stand by that statement are you now
calling on him to resign
yes wow do you believe he should be
impeached and removed from office
let's take one thing at a time here i
think you should resign
i understand that the state legislature
may decide to impeach i don't know that
for fact i've not read all that data
he's got to go embracing him in his
self-defense
to say that these are commonplace kind
of embraces that he made in the
allegations against him
do you condone that look
i'm not gonna fly spec this
i'm sure there are some embraces that
were totally innocent
but apparently the attorney general
decided there were things that weren't
if i could ask you a question about the
evictions
no thank you on the evictions in the
moratorium that lapsed on saturday night
what is your strategy
to prevent potentially millions of
people from being evicted
from their homes given what we are told
your administration is considering
a targeted moratorium is likely to face
legal challenges
any call for moratorium based on the
supreme court
recent decision is likely to face
obstacles
i've indicated to the cdc i'd like to
look at other alternatives than the one
that
is in power in existence which the court
has declared they're not going to
allow to continue and the cdc will have
something to announce to you
in the next hour to two hours whoa
on overseas coronavirus vaccines should
other
high income countries follow the lead of
the united states
and increase donations to low and middle
income countries
i think those countries that have been
able to cover their population
and have the ability to provide either
dollars
and or vaccine for the hundred or so
poor nations that need help should do so
we had that discussion
at the g7 a number of those countries
said they were going to do that
for people wondering why the cdc about
moratorium on eviction
from the beginning that's been a
provision sort of directed by and
managed by the cdc
it's not totally intuitive necessary
necessarily i understand that but
he's sort of hinting the cdc will be
announcing something abbott are
personally making decisions
that are harming their own citizens i
believe the results of their decisions
are not good for their constituents
and it's clear to me and to most the
medical experts that the decisions
being made like not allowing mass
mandates in school and the like
are bad health policy bad health policy
i have a question about something that
you just said i'm sure you do
thank you uh you just said there is no
wall
high enough and no ocean wide enough to
protect us
from the virus so what is the thinking
behind letting
untested and unvaccinated migrants cross
the southern border
into u.s cities in record numbers
there is what we're doing we have not
withdrawn
the order that is sometimes critical or
criticized saying that unvaccinated
people
should be go back across the border but
unaccompanied children is a different
story
because there's that's the most humane
thing to do
is to test them and to treat them and
not send them back
spoken with alone cuomo today i have not
and then one other question on the virus
you just said we have
we have to continue our aggressive
efforts to get the unvaccinated vaccine
other countries have found a lot of
success in requiring vaccines in public
places
new york city just announced today that
they'll require vaccines for restaurants
and gyms do you think more cities and
states should
institute rules like that i do and are
you going to publicly call on them
should they institute a vaccine casper
or it's up to each city and safe to
figure that out on their own i'm sorry
do you think that they should institute
a vaccine passport type system or some
sort of verification
to use public spaces i don't think they
need to do that i think they just need
to give the authority or those
restaurants or
businesses to say in order to come in
you have to
give proof that you've been vaccinated
or that you can't come in
take a couple of days mr president can i
ask you about the news of the day one
more on on
governor cuomo you you're calling for
him to resign now my question is do you
think he should be prosecuted
and what is your message to the woman
who have now accused him of sexually
harassing them and abusing them
look what i said was if the
investigation
attorney general concluded yeah that the
allegations were correct
that back in march that i would
recommend he resigned that's what i'm
doing today
i've not read the report i don't know
the deal that's a typical reporter kind
of baiting question where it's like
he doesn't get involved in prosecution
and he doesn't know the women he's
he just had there's just a report and he
should resign you know eviction
moratoriums can you explain a little bit
more why it took so long to have a
possible eviction moratorium
be put into place there was there were
people this inspired on saturday i'm
wondering there are
folks who are saying it took too long
for this to happen well
look um
the courts made it clear that the
existing moratorium
was not constitutional it wouldn't stand
and they made that clear back in i guess
july 15th or july 18th
in the meantime what i've been pushing
for and calling for
is we have billions of dollars that have
given to states
to provide for rent and utilities
for those people who can't afford to
stay in their homes because they can't
on an apartment they can't pay their
rent and so we're urging them to
distribute those funds to the landlords
i believe that would take care of the
vast majority of what needs to be done
to keep people in their
in their in their apartments now and so
that's what we're working on
some states have done it and some
communities have but they have not
the money is theirs not we don't have to
send it out it's been
sent out to the states and counties
billions of dollars for the express
purpose
of providing for back rent and rent the
people
who are in the middle of this crisis
and that's there that's what we're
pushing now and we've been pushing that
that's the immediate thing to do take
one more question
thank you so much there was an
expectation that you would be announcing
again new uh vaccines to the world today
on you other than the ones you promised
are you
ready to send more vaccines to the world
and there is a delegation from the white
house going to brazil tomorrow
are they bringing more vaccines are they
announcing more things
to brazil no are they announcing more
vaccines overall
overall and then to brazil for the
delegation coming to brazil tomorrow
we'll be bringing vaccines
uh the answer is i don't know with the
delegation going physically as vaccines
with them we have provided vaccines to
bring in the announcement are they
announcing there
there's a need for several billion doses
around the world we have committed to
over a half a billion doses
and we're trying to provide for more and
provide for the capacity
of countries like india to be able to
produce the vaccine
themselves and we're helping them do
that
that's what we're doing now and we're
trying to we're pr and by the way it's
free
we're not charging anybody anything and
we're trying to do as much as we
possibly can
thank you
is about to announce a new partial
eviction
moratorium that's pretty implied can you
tell us
any more about that and are you sure
it's going to pass supreme court muster
the answer is twofold one i've sought
out constitutional scholars
to determine what is the best
possibility
that would come from executive action or
the cdc's judgment
what could they do that was most likely
to pass
muster constitutionally
the bulk of the constitutional
scholarship says
that it's not likely to pass
constitutional muster
number one but there are several key
scholars
who think that it may and it's worth the
effort but
the present you could not the courts
already ruled on the present
eviction moratorium so i think what
you're going to see and i
look i want to make it clear i told you
i would not tell the justice department
or the
medical experts or scientists what they
should say or do
so i don't want to get ahead the cdc has
to make this i ask the cdc to go back
and consider other options that may be
available to them
you're going to hear from them what
those other options are
i have been informed they're about to
make a judgment
as to potential other options whether
that option
will pass constitutional
measure with this administration i can't
tell you
i don't know there are a few scholars
who say it will
and others who say it's not likely to
but at a minimum by the time it gets
litigated it will probably give some
additional time
while we're getting that 45 billion
dollars out to people
who are in fact behind in the rent and
don't have the money
that's why it was passed in in the act
that we passed in the beginning my
administration
and it went to the states we were under
the impression that the states were
moving this money out
relatively rapidly so for example
if i'm in an apartment if you're in an
apartment
and you're behind on four or five months
rent
and let's say your rent is two thousand
dollars a month i'm just making this up
out of the blue
and you're behind you need ten thousand
dollars to catch up
home and hardly anybody has that ten
thousand dollars
but there's money that the states have
that one can give to the landlord that
ten thousand dollars
to the background the future
rent it's unlikely at least the hope is
since they have been made whole to that
point
that they'd be inclined because the
economy is
growing inclined not to throw someone
out in the street
keep that person no guarantee keep that
person in the apartment
keep these kids in the same school
district and
count on being able to have the
opportunity for that
that person to be able who's may now be
employed to pay their rent
but in the meantime i've asked that
isn't there any safety valve we can put
in
and it's the one i explained to you
again
cdc will announce that and the details
of exactly how it works
i'm not telling i told them i want them
to take a look i didn't tell them what
they had to do
right and my hope is it's going to be
a new moratorium
that in some way i'm not going to
announce it now let them announce it
in some way covers close to 90 of the
american people that's the rumor
yeah and uh so that's
all i can tell you now thank you very
much what's the difference
he said let them explain that to you
okay
i don't want to get too far ahead thank
you president
is kovacs doing enough to get shots in
arms
off he goes
to deliver the message that you seem to
be delivering today
what did he say to you in that
discussion
thank you sir
uh oh is the door blocked his mask
the door's um is the door locked or
all right guys you know what because we
are getting so dangerously close
to 85 000 uh twitch followers
let's just look a little a little bit of
my interview with mike pillow from
earlier today okay guys we're keep we're
about to hit 85 000 on twitch it's gonna
be crazy
if we hit it we'll keep playing the
interview here we go cyber symposium
five million dollars for anyone that's
there
which is we've invited now we have over
a hundred cyber cyber forensic experts
from around the country and a couple
from
out of the out of this country what is
that what does that mean a cyber foreign
what's that credential a cyber forensic
account
they have cissp but it's more than that
these are
these are guys that protect our country
a lot of them work for the government
that
when you have a cyber attack these are
experts that can read these packet
captures
that can just you know what actually
happened the uh you know it shows where
the attack came from
the computer that was intruded how many
votes were flipped they're going to read
all this during the 72 hours we're going
to go through all
50 states and a pack could capture
everybody
is like a picture you can't change you
can't alter that's true
but mike and this is so important
because i've looked i saw the packet
captures and i saw the the the numbers
and i went to
in preparation for the interview to be
thorough i went to some cyber experts on
this
what they told me is that what you
previewed i don't remember if it was on
frank's speech or on newsmax or where it
was a couple weeks ago but you showed
the numbers scrolling
they said that that's absolutely
meaningless
those are called hex dumps and it's just
a way to look at
computer memory right we just put big
massive those are not the captures so
we put b-roll those are from the
election those are
every single outlet including cnn i just
did
a two and a half hour interview with
them about okay that's to show you
what this data if you're any kind of a
cyber guy you can decipher and say well
that was from the 2020 election
okay i should have told you that so what
you're saying is
what you put up there is the style of
what you will be unveiling at the
symposium but it is not the actual data
and those were actual data
it was actual data okay actual
so if you talked to guys that wasn't now
that wasn't packet captured that was
data
from the packet captures yep that were
captured so what we're gonna do at the
cyber symposium
don't you guys understand that it's so
obvious what he's talking about
you're going to be able to go up to
imagine this we're going to have
on stage we're going to have a panel and
we're going to go just like election
night and the state
of new hampshire goes to donald trump
whoa
this will be the real election okay and
on the
to the side of the stage we have a cyber
cyber center
any of these politicians or the media
if you got you're invited yourself david
if you want to come and then then you
can get your five million
dollar prize you can bring your own
cyber guys absolutely
if you're beside the stage you'll be
able to punch in a state
or a county or the whole election if you
punch in the whole election you got
donald trump winning 80 million to 68
million
but now you do this now listen we're
gonna have these hundred cyber guys that
came from
all over the country these are none of
them know each other they were just they
were they were
you know we invited and they they've
called in they've added them that
they're the
they're good they're the best okay so
they're gonna divide up into groups like
let's say eight to a group
and we're gonna give them a state here's
the statement sounds fun
georgia here's the raw data and they're
gonna sit there and make sure
a hundred percent that what what i'm
telling you is the truth
they'll go through it and they're going
to go through it i see
i see and they're going to and then
we're going to have them on the stage
and they're going to have
the people it's like reading a language
let's say let's say this
was all written in chinese you'd have to
have people there that could read the
chinese
and say yup this is what it says now is
that mandarin or cantonese that he's
talking about
now since it's non-subjective every
cyber guy will say the exact same thing
and when you're watching that from home
now when you're watching that
cyber guy or anybody in the world that
sees this will be a hundred percent
not 92 percent by the time the symposium
is over
everyone democrats republicans liberals
conservatives
are going to go wow we need to do
something now this was an attack by
china
this is real these heroes that captured
this information
which is these packet captures our
government should have been doing this
because the democrats weren't it but
yeah but
you don't they said oh they're none of
the machines were online
so why would you it'd be like getting
flood insurance when you say hey there's
not going to be any water
what they like to yeah they like the
american people
so there i'm i'm out of breath from all
of this information that you're giving
me mike
there's a couple other things i want to
get to and maybe on the i know your time
is short so maybe we can keep these
short
i am not a christian so i may not be in
a position to understand this but
if donald trump was selected by god as
you are certain that he was
why would god allow joe biden to even
become
president and force you to go through
all of this why not
just put trump in the white house again
well i believe
i believe that that's that's part of
this divine divine thing that's going on
because
really people don't look let me tell you
people do not look for hope
unless things are going bad huh and this
that's why i believe this will be the
greatest revival for jesus and we
believe once again one nation under god
ever because all these people including
yourself
are going to see miracles unfold here
mike are you saying
even even even a jewish guy like me will
see jesus
okay what's that even a jewish guy like
me
you're gonna see miracles you're gonna
see miracles miracles
you're gonna see miracles unfold you can
believe whatever you want but you're
gonna see things that you thought were
impossible
okay happen and you're saying you asked
me why would god
why would god let this happen yeah well
if you don't people don't look for i'll
give an example
all right okay guys so that's that's
gonna be with the full interview is
gonna be released at some point in the
future maybe even later today
but that's as far as we're going that's
only about 60
of the interview okay we've got another
40 and it's it's wild okay guys so
thank you for joining me mike pillow
interview later
it's all happening on the edge of our
seats waiting for the full interview
see everybody very soon